on october 5th 2017 in downtown hereford
england 27 year old harry godzill was
going about his day as usual he had
taken a day off from his office job to
catch up on some errands and all was
going swimmingly so far he had woken up
early to make a lovely cup of tea and
take his dog for a walk and had noticed
how nice the weather was for the time of
year with hardly any of the usual rain
after a rich fulfilling morning of
finishing up the dishes and laundry at
his flat he was taking a walk to the
corner grocery store to pick up some
milk potatoes and ground beef for the
shepherd's pie he planned to make for
dinner all in all it was a good day to
be harry godsol surely nothing strange
or unusual would come along to derail
this perfectly pleasant and ordinary day
out of nowhere and into what was meant
to be harry godzill's day to himself
suddenly strolled a truly odd sight
walking down the sidewalk towards him
was a person in a full spacesuit like
those worn by nasa and international
space station crew members in the middle
of hereford casual as you please was an
honest-to-god spaceman harry attempted
to walk around this bizarre figure and
carry on with his day but it
deliberately blocked his path and spoke
with a booming voice asking if he would
be willing to join in the fight against
the moon monsters well at this point
harry had just about enough of this
nonsense and his natural penchant for
sarcasm came out oh absolutely you
nutter he said i'm ready to go right now
got my toothbrush and everything let's
fly spaceman he rolled his eyes and once
more attempted to pass the astronaut
rather than taking the hint the figure
was overjoyed at last it declared a
brave warrior hiding in plain sight
admits these pastoral and bucolic humans
let us away fair meet fellow and earn
the glory of heroes we fly
before harry could turn and run away
from what was certainly not an ordinary
man the spaceman grabbed him pulling him
into its unnaturally strong arms and
activated the jetpack strapped to its
back there was a massive sonic boom
shattering every piece of glass in a 300
meter radius as they took off into the
sky at a speed of 25 000 kilometers per
hour they broke through the atmosphere
and ascended into space so quickly that
surrounding observational satellites
could not get a clear image of the two
on their journey harry godzill had been
on an ordinary quest to have a day of
chores and a hearty dinner and now he
had vanished into outer space his body
was never found and he could not be
positively identified on any satellite
images the residents of hereford had
their minds wiped with amnestics by the
scp foundation in order to keep the
story from getting out and harry godsol
was officially declared missing three
months later when no trace of him had
surfaced he was presumed dead to this
day he has never been found it is
uncertain what he saw on his trip into
the stars or what became of him all that
we know is on that fateful day harry
encountered the entity known as
scp-1233 also known as the lunatic or
the moon champion
scp-1233 is a humanoid entity of unknown
species wearing a spacesuit resembling
the emu or extra-vehicular mobility unit
model complete with an opaque visor and
attached jetpack the suit does not
behave like an ordinary spacesuit
capable of withstanding small arms fire
anti-tank munitions landmine blasts and
exposure to incredibly high temperatures
including complete submersion and magma
without any visible damage no radio
microwave or x-ray scanning has been
able to break through the material of
the suit the jetpack is outfitted with a
high-powered rocket propulsion system
capable of accelerating up to 40 500
kilometers per hour at a rate of
acceleration and deceleration that
should instantly kill any human wearing
it in addition to its resilience
scp-1233 displays an anomalous level of
physical strength able to lift and throw
items up to a weight of 65 000 kilograms
without exhaustion the moon champion is
capable of cognizant speech and is
fluent in a large number of languages
able to switch its language depending on
the dominant tongue of whatever area it
is in it communicates via a loudspeaker
installed in its suit and speaks using
flowery language in a loud authoritative
voice that is usually interpreted as
male though the gender of the entity if
it even has a concept of gender at all
is unknown it has a strong grasp of
language but like its behavior its
speech patterns are odd erratic and
sometimes completely impossible to
understand
scp-1233 appears every four to five
years each time following a similar
pattern first the entity will fall from
an unknown height above the surface of
the earth falling at a terminal velocity
similar to that of a small meteorite or
a vehicle re-entering the atmosphere as
it falls scp-1233 will emit red-orange
thermal radiance causing it to be
mistaken for a shooting star if its
descent occurs at night then it will
crash land on the ground leaving a large
crater and causing a small earthquake in
the vicinity it tends to land within 7
to 30 kilometers from a town usually a
smaller municipality with a population
of 30 000 or less then 1233 will climb
out of its crater and head towards the
town on foot or by flight it does not
ordinarily head directly to the town and
has been observed taking its time taking
the scenic route if you will and
engaging in a variety of random detours
scp-1233 has taken the time to inspect
various objects including farm equipment
buildings and plants occasionally it
will pick these plants and has been
observed plucking the petals from a
flower in what can only be identified as
an interplanetary variation on the
classic he loves me he loves me not game
sometimes it will chase after insects
such as grasshoppers and butterflies
demanding that they stop and allow the
entity to observe them once it
accidentally crushed a ladybug between
its hands and wept inconsolably for a
duration of 25 straight minutes in
addition to interacting with insects it
also attempts to speak to various
animals it has been spotted attempting
to interrogate a cow about its motives
greeting a bird as if it were the owner
of a house it was perched on the roof of
and asking a frog where the nearest
place to get something good to eat was
it is unknown what or even if the entity
eats it has been seen pulling root
vegetables from the ground or picking
fruit from bushes and trees and shoving
them directly into its closed visor
crushing them uselessly in what seems to
be an attempt to eat them naturally this
attempt is fruitless do you get it i
joke fruitless because he
anyway when it is not attempting to eat
or interact with new life forms
scp-1233 occasionally will march
directly into large bodies of water such
as lakes or ponds then emerge from them
and shake the water off of its suit it
will also stand completely still for
durations of up to several hours the
reason for any of this behavior like
basically everything else about the
entity is unknown once scp-1233 has
reached the limits of the town it will
attempt to engage with the population
due to its curious nature heightened
strength and lack of any understanding
of proper human behavior this often
results in confusion disruption and a
great deal of property damage a typical
example of scp-1233's interactions with
the general public is found in archive
security camera footage from a bakery in
saratoga springs new york by the name of
sam sweets on august 9 2009
scp-1233 entered the cafe an attempt to
speak with its co-owner 32-year-old bob
parsons parsons greeted the entity with
a friendly if perplexed attitude
presuming it to be a cosplayer taking a
snack break from a nearby comic book
convention the entity identified itself
as moon champion champion of the moon's
defender of space justice and destroyer
of evil after introducing itself as cp
1233 asked bob if he was the president
of earth he was understandably amused by
the question laughing hard enough to
bring tears to his eyes and offered the
entity a free cookie in exchange for
cheering him up scp-1234 identified the
cookie incorrectly obviously as a
parakeet and smashed the confection
uselessly into its unopened visor
scattering crumbs all over the counter
and floor it then attempted to engage
bob in conversation about the moon
monsters that it was dedicated to
fighting in its homeland the majestic
and magnificent moon kingdom
scp-1233 then asked if it could perhaps
befriend a dog and take it back to the
moon and attempted to recruit bob to
fight alongside it against the moon
monsters bob with a great deal of polite
confusion insisted that he had to stay
on earth and continue to run the bakery
in order to keep the citizens fed 1233
thanked him for his time bit him
farewell and crashed through a concrete
while leaving a distinct astronaut
shaped hole
scp-1233 spent the rest of the day
wandering into traffic and causing
several accidents breaking through glass
storefronts challenging a fire hydrant
to hand-to-hand combat making a pile of
stolen bicycles in the middle of a
public park and collecting as many dogs
as it could hold then attempting to use
said dogs as a type of currency to
purchase even more dogs i honestly think
that's genius finally after leaving all
of this head-scratch-inducing
destruction in its wake
scp-1233 activated its jetpack and took
off out of the earth's atmosphere
apparently returning to the moon none of
scp-1233's claims about the moon have
been verified though the foundation
maintains contact with lunar area 32 to
keep an eye out for moon people a moon
kingdom and the moon monsters 1233 spoke
of in the meantime the foundation is
simply doing its best to contain
scp-1233 and minimize its damage as much
as possible because of the anomalous
physical properties of scp-1233 there is
no way to physically contain it at this
point in time until a method of physical
containment can be found secondary
measures will be taken to keep this
lunar lunatic from causing any more
havoc or at the very least reduce its
levels of havoc as much as possible
there's only so much havoc we can
prevent in this world especially when
you have an astronaut plummeting from
the sky on a semi-regular basis the
foundation satellite observation network
argos or atmospheric reconnaissance
global observation system enters
priority two high alert status once
three years and six months have passed
since
scp-1233's last appearance when 1233 is
spotted in the upper thermosphere a
foundation mobile task force will be
deployed in whatever populated area is
close to the entity's estimated landing
point there they will prepare to
administer amnestics and provide a cover
story such as immersive theater piece
prank show 2001 a space odyssey remake
to any civilians who witness
scp-1233's arrival in addition to these
measures there is to be a media blackout
in place in order to prevent knowledge
of 1233 from spreading task force
operatives are authorized to grab the
smartphones of any bystanders attempting
to take photos videos tick tocks or any
other documentation of the entity and
promptly smash them on the ground in
front of them it's not like they're
going to stay mad they're all getting
their memories wiped anyway if scp-1230
stays in the area for an unusually long
amount of time a mass amnestization of
the town or city where it landed may be
authorized though the task force is
permitted to interact with civilians in
order to slow the spread of information
and provide cover stories no interaction
between foundation personnel and
scp-1233 is permitted under any
circumstances even if they think it
would be really funny no matter how epic
your moon man prank might be it's never
worth your life
now go check out nasa lies
scp-2001 space oddity and how to
actually beat scp-3008 the infinite ikea
for more scp videos that'll make you
laugh rather than scream